I am such a believer in handwritten
letters pilotpin is actually our
season-long partner because I love
handwritten letters so much our world is
more digital than ever which makes
physical letters more important and
special than ever this next story proves
just that meet Amy and Dana they met at
summer camp
but lost touch and they reconnected on
Facebook but it wasn't until Dana's son
had cancer that Amy wrote her a
handwritten letter and it led to more
letters and their friendship was renewed
it also sparked a project that connected
hundreds of other people but we're going
to get to that later please welcome Dana
and Amy everybody
[Applause]
so much for having us yeah you look
beautiful I saw you on the lobby on the
way in and I was like God they look
beautiful I love the colors so you were
Camp counselors is that how y'all met
that's how we met we were Camp Olympia
in Trinity Texas and we spent yeah we
probably spent two weeks together and
you know how you just make a connection
with somebody we both have huge
personalities yeah and so it was like
bang we had a great time and then I
would love y'all okay yeah we then we
spent we walked away and we spent the
next 30 Years doing life totally apart
and uh I always had our name kind of
kicking around in my head and wonder
what happened to her I get on Facebook
just like everybody else I was like boom
there's Dana and so I friend request her
I found out right away she has five kids
four girls and the youngest uh Parker
her only son and he has you know I found
out he had cancer yeah and so we
messaged back and forth I was like I'm
praying for you thinking about you and
then when he relapsed it was like a bolt
from God out of the sky it was like you
know what I'm a writer I'm gonna start
writing them letters so the whole thing
kicked off when I started to write Dana
and Parker letters at Saint at the
Ronald McDonald House in Memphis oh wow
what what was your experience like just
hearing from around nowhere well first
of all I was kind of surprised because
we had not seen her you know besides
Facebook here and there yeah and so many
years but then
I was so touched because we got Parker
and I got a lot of support and gifts and
things like that but the difference with
Amy is that she kept writing she kept
writing us week after week and Parker
was like who is this woman and I'm like
someone dad and I worked with at a camp
years ago and he's like how cool though
that she thinks enough of us to write us
every week yeah so she continued that
and Parker fought a very brave battle he
never complained and our worst day
happened in January of 2015 and so we
went home and there was a ladder in the
mail and the next week a letter and the
next week a letter
Amy continued to write me so finally I
wrote her back and it was just such a
great thing we became pen pals I was
able to share my grief in a safe space
and it wasn't just myself that started
looking forward to her letters my family
would say did it come yet you know every
week it just made such a difference she
still writes me every single week oh my
gosh I love it oh try not to cry okay
wait and you see you had an epiphany so
from this so what was it well this free
space was created between the two of us
where I did a lot of sharing too and it
just impacted me profoundly and I was
like you know what if I can have this
one random girl in Louisiana this one
Facebook friend just blow up my life
what what else is out there yeah so I
was like I'm gonna write all the 580 of
these people so I don't know that I
thought I was really gonna do it wait
580 Whoopi where'd you get that number
Facebook those are that's how many
friends you have on Facebook that's what
I had yeah God okay I'm like I don't I'm
not on so I don't know but I'm like
that's a lot yeah no it was a lot so I
put all this paper man yeah yeah I
started pulling those names out and it
just blew up my life because you know I
wrote to a girl who helped me when my
grandmother died I wrote to my seventh
grade band friend I wrote to a guy I
dated in college I wrote to a girl I
danced with at a wedding you know and
then all these people that just were
names on a list I was like you know what
it really is I'm connected to this
treasure
full of amazing people and there's just
so much hope in that yeah and connecting
with people in those relationships
that's really what life is about you the
older we get we realize it's that simple
right right yeah and that connection is
so cool and so the letter has turned
into even more writing so tell us about
the book right well I was about three
quarters through writing up 600 letters
and I was like you know what we got a
special story here with so much hope in
it I was like I'm gonna write a book and
so the book is called dear Dana that
time I went crazy and wrote All 580 of
my Facebook friends ladder the longest
subtitles
and so it takes those two narratives so
it takes Dana and I story and a lot of
Dana's words are in it you know are pen
paling at the beginning and then it runs
the uh Facebook letter story through
that yeah and uh we went on a book tour
this summer you know go on a book tour
with your best friend 17 different
cities yeah and one of the best things
was people showed up over and over again
Facebook friends people of that 580.
with their letter and pristine you know
condition they're like like they were a
rock star because they had this letter
yeah kept them in special places and
it's just another illustration how
something like a deliberate act like a
handwritten letter can really it really
can change someone's life absolutely
yeah well we shared this story with
pilot makers of friction to go to
erasable pen of the Kelly Clarkson show
and they love celebrating those who
create fearlessly and of handwriting 580
letters isn't that I don't know what it
is so pilate wanted to do something to
honor Parker so they are making a five
thousand dollar donation to Saint Jude
Children's Research Hospital in his name
[Applause]
it's a hard thing I can't even imagine
going through but I do love that
something beautiful came out of it and
something positive that is connected to
Parker you know so that will go on
forever which is beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going home
[Music]